hello everyone and welcome to that
special day of the year that is the
birthday of the great Bobby Fisher as
every year it comes a day after the
birthday of the great Jose Raul
capablanca yeah you guys of course know
that on International women's day it is
kappa's birthday and the next day is
Fisher's birthday and here is one game
that I still haven't shown on the
channel it's actually one of Bobby
Fisher's greatest games ever against
American Grandmaster Robert Bayern not
to be confused with Donald Byron uh
Bobby Fischer a few years prior to this
game uh defeated Donald Byron in his uh
famous uh game of the century when he
was only 13 years old and that game
traveled the entire world but basically
overnight
um and I mean it's still considered one
of the greatest games ever played even
today so that's not him this is his
brother Robert barn and although he's a
a great player in his own right he
um uh even won the USG Championship not
this one but the one in 1972 when Bobby
Fischer was playing for the world's
championship title against borisposky in
1974 he played in the candidates
tournament and he represented United
States in the chess Olympiad uh nine
times uh uh and and he won seven medals
in those competitions but as you know
history often uh has a witty way around
things that he's mostly remembered for
for uh losing this game to Bobby Fischer
at least you know uh uh amongst chess
enthusiasts as Bobby Fischer was uh one
of the the most famous players that ever
lived and in those days he was
definitely the most famous so let's
check it out it's from the 1963 to 64 us
championship and the reason why it's
63-64 is because it starts in December
and ends in January of next year and uh
he has the black pieces against the
Robert Byron uh Fisher won the five
previous USA Championship the
Championships that he played in and he
also won this one actually with a
perfect score with 11 out of 11. but
we're gonna discuss that a little bit
after we check out the game because the
game is simply spectacular so here uh
Robert opens with D4 uh we have Knight
to F6 by Fisher c c four we have G6 G3
now uh and pawn to C6 so the the king's
Indian defense by Fisher and now Bishop
to G2 and here uh Bayern says that he
prepared it very well for Fisher because
last year uh in the uh 1960 to 63 us
Championship uh the Robert played Ponte
D5 the game continued with a very crazy
variation of B5 D captures B captures
and C four C captures and D7 check
Knight B captures on D7 and Bishop to G2
now attacking Fisher's Rook Rook the B8
and here Knight to a three Bishop to G7
and both players just castled and Fisher
had this sort of a weak seep on what he
had immense pressure along the uh along
the this diagonal and the B file and
eventually he won the game so here uh
Robert tried something else he played
Bishop to G2 we have Pawn to D5 now as
D5 was not prevented and now C captures
C captures and now Knight to C3 with
Bishop to G7 E3 and fish are just
castles we have Knight gte2 Knight to C6
and here we have Castles by by Robert we
have Fanta B6 Pawn to B3 and now Bishop
to A6 putting pressure on this uh
diagonal The Rook is still on F1 and
Bishop to A3 uh also with a very similar
idea a Fisher plays Rook to E8 he moves
the rook and uh Here Comes Queen to D2 a
very interesting idea uh that was
presented by a a a gentleman who was
observing the game but he only asked uh
Fisher about it after the game because
he he needed by playing Rook d8 Fischer
wanted to play Pawn to E5 so he asked
would would F4 be a good idea here and
okay I mean you uh the five-time U.S
Champion uh who also uh crushed the
tournament you you suggest the move I
mean that's a very bold thing to do uh
Fisher actually replies with the top um
uh evaluation uh aligned by the engine
he says just Pawn to E6 you will
challenge White's Bishop with Bishop to
f8 and you will double Rooks on the C
file that's exactly what the engine
gives even something like B5 and queen
to B6 can be played so that's the idea
and black will always have the upper
hand but here we have Queen to D2 by
Robert and now comes Ponte E5 by Fisher
the captors Knight captures and now
comes Rook F to D1 and this is the star
move of the game uh because it's the one
that allows Fisher this incredible
brilliancy and it's always the theme
uh which Rook to put on D1 or which book
to put on E1 or which Rook to put on C1
uh it's uh even though you understand
the basic principles and which rule goes
where when you're actually playing the
game you you never know this and here
Fisher says in his book uh my 60
memorable games uh add another uh to
those Melancholy case histories uh
entitled the wrong Rook the correct one
was Rook 8 D1 and this is the most
interesting part what happens if Rook
ate the D1 because after Rook after D1
uh what follows is a brilliancy but uh
it's also very important to explore what
happens after Rook a D1 uh because it
wasn't played in the game the reason
it's so much better is that Knight to D3
here by Fisher wouldn't be so
spectacular because just Queen to C2 and
now what what do you do here the Knight
isn't really on a great Square you're
threatening to pick it up you have to go
back with something like Knight D5 and
then you start capturing Knight captures
on D5 and so on and white is just better
tonight the D3 is impossible if you play
Rook a to D1 another idea
uh that becomes possible which uh Fisher
says that he planned if uh the he didn't
plan to play it he he had it prepared in
his home analysis maybe if Rook a D1 is
played and then for example if uh
Knight's the E4 he gives the following
line Knight captures an E4 D captures on
e4 Bishop captures an e for now Queen
captures and D2 Rook captures and
knights the C4 attacking The Rook here
and the bishop on A3 Bishop capture 78
Knight captures on D2 attacks the other
Rook so Rook to D1 Knight back to C4
attacks the bishop on A3 and now B
captures on C4 and now after Rook
captures an A8 you get this position
where you could argue that black is
slightly better due to play being on
both sides of the board and Fisher
having the the bishop pair however
average told Fisher that he he had a he
had mistakes in his calculation and that
instead of B captures and C4 white
should just Play Bishop to C6 now
attacking the rook and now you have
problems and the best thing you can do
is capture here and Knight captures on
A3 and then Bishop captures on E8 Bishop
characters on E2 attacks The Rook here
and The Rook to D7 and now the df7 pawn
will fall and white has uh basically a
winning advantage and Fisher was uh very
very interested in this line that
averback suggested and then he thought
well isn't it there anything better that
can be played here isn't is is the game
I played in Fisher won a brilliant
surprise for this game is it flawed if
uh if uh rubber band actually played the
correct Rook to D1 uh with there still
would there be nothing that I could do
and then he found it if Rook ate the D1
uh the idea was uh Queen to D7 and now
none of White's ideas basically work and
black has a very clear plan of what to
do the rule can come easily into the
game the queen is coming to F5 You're
Gonna Play Knight to F3 check eliminate
whites a stronger a light score bishop
and the uh the whole point of the game
is that Knight captures on D5 is not
possible and the reason it's not
possible is because now after Knight
captures on D5 Bishop captures on D5 uh
there's Rook a to d8 and now there is no
good move you can make here it's a
really really a silly position but uh
basically you would want to play E4 here
but if play E4 just Knight to F3 check
picks up the queen so the bishop is
essential in guarding of the F3 Square
you could play something like Queen to
C2 but then you run into this very
annoying line of Queen to B5 now putting
pressure on the Knight and after Knight
the C3 attacking the queen there's Queen
to A5 now attacking the bishop here and
once you play Bishop to B2 Rook the C8
and black has a significant significant
Advantage here as uh everything is uh
hanging and being pressured there's
immense pressure here on the C3 Square
the rook and F1 is hanging uh also uh I
mean uh it is just a wonderful position
the bishop here I can't really move
freely has to be regarding that F3
Square all the time so it's a it's a
wonderful uh position for black so maybe
not uh winning by force but it would be
very very hard to refute this so that
was Fisher's response and what the play
if the correct move was played after
Knight captures on E5 however Rook 8 to
D1 was not played in the game Rook F the
D1 was played and this may makes a huge
difference in the position but you guys
of course will for those of you who
still haven't seen this game you will
have a chance to show why now Fisher
does play Knights the D3 and now the
same idea no longer works the one that
we've shown with Queen the C2 however uh
here Robert still plays it he plays
Queen to C2 and now uh it's absolutely
crushing what Fisher has so feel free to
pause the video and win the game for
Fisher while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh well brilliancy as the game did win a
brilliant surprise and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
not that night captures an F2 and now
you have to capture the Knight otherwise
your position just uh you know crumbles
so King captures an F2 and now Knights
the G4 check King to G1 and Knight
captures on E3 attacking the queen and
the Rook Queen to D2 and here's the real
star move of the game because up until
this point uh Robert was thinking why is
why why is Fisher doing this this is uh
this is just lost for him there's
nothing in this line that um that is
mysterious or is just a silly silly move
he sacrificed material for nothing and
now there's there's no good way to
continue but then
uh after the game uh Robert Byron uh
says this about about the game and as I
said pondering why Fisher would choose
such a line because it was so obviously
lost for black there suddenly came at
the idea of Knight captures on G2 and
this is the star move of the game you
could also start with D4 because both
moves are essential uh but Knight
captures um on G2 and this dazzling move
came as a shocker and the culminating
combination is of such depth that even
at the very moment at which I resigned
both the grand Masters who were
commenting on the game uh gameplay for
The Spectators in a separate room
believed that I had won the game so they
they also believed that the game was
just winning for him uh for Robert but
here after Knight captures on G2 look at
what happens King captures and G2 Now
Pawn to D4 with the threat of picking up
the Knight but also this opens up the
diagonal for the light Square Bishop now
Knight captures on D4 it is a it is
giving up on but Bishop the B7 check the
compensation is is just too too immense
and now there is no good Square for the
king if you try to go to a dark Square
let's say you play King to G1 then look
at this just Bishop captures on D4 check
and you resign because if you capture
then Rook the E1 check and now uh you
can't capture because then the queen
hangs so you have to move the king uh
with the King to F2 now Queen captures
on D4 comes with the track and now okay
doesn't matter what captures you're
gonna capture the rook and A1 you're up
upon you're up the exchange you are of
course completely winning here so after
Bishop to B7 check King the F1 was
played trying uh to go for a light
square but here Fisher just played Queen
to D7 and it was in this position on
move 21 that rubberband resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here so absolutely a spectacular game by
Fisher not just the game the entire
tournament like I said he won uh this
edition of the US Chess Championship as
well with a perfect score of 11 out of
11. uh but here you resign because
there's just no reply to um uh the queen
to H3 check and okay you could uh maybe
try try some moves but there really
aren't any look at this the The Rook
controls this uh the light Square Bishop
controls this diagonal uh the dark
Square Bishop also very very impressive
the queen is coming to H3 you you just
can't uh hold on to this like if Knight
to F3 doesn't really matter just Queen
to H3 with check and now you you really
don't have a move with Queen to G2 uh
this this blocks check but now you can
play Queen to G4 how are you stopping
this this is uh
you can prolong the game for a few moves
but it just uh makes no sense like if
you play Rook to D3 you can defend the
Knight there's even Bishop to A6 now uh
man
it's impossible to even suggest a move
for white because the position is so bad
and that's why after Queen to D7 and
Robert uh wanted nothing more with this
game and he he just resigned so really a
brilliant showing by Fisher and like I
said uh here are the sorry those are not
the standings those are the different
standings let me just uh
find these standings uh
there we have it all right
I prepared them only I prepared them
under a different name by mistake so
sorry about that
yeah here they are so these are the
standings of the 1963-64 US Championship
so as you can see Robert James Fisher
won the event with a perfect score of 11
out of 11. that's absolutely spectacular
followed by uh Larry Evans with seven
and a half points then Paul benko with
seven similar chefsky Antonio City
rubberbine Raymond Weinstein Arthur
bisgaar Willie Madison Edmund Madness
Robert Henry steinmeyer and Donald Byrne
in last place with two and a half out of
11 points and um uh there's even a joke
that uh Hans mock said that after the
the tournament that Larry Evans was in
fact the winner of the tournament and
that Bobby Fischer just won the
exhibition as uh well it wasn't really a
question whether Fisher would win the
tournament I mean he wins every U.S
Chess Championship here he ever played
in uh it was uh you know it was merely a
a question of who actually wins second
place that's the winner of the
tournament as Fisher we all know Fisher
will win but yeah that's the game and if
you if you still haven't seen uh the the
game against Robert's brother against
Donald Byron at the famous game of the
century do check it out it will be the
first link in the description below and
if by any chance you haven't seen my
Bobby Fischer Saga do check that out as
well as you will learn a lot about the
one of the greatest chess Champions who
ever lived a Robert James Fisher so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
I thought we celebrate Bobby's aviat uh
birthday uh birthday birthday with with
a nice one so uh I hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank a very very Dame a
lobo ravishing reptiles YouTube and uh
Williams for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day